Marvel's Hall H panel at this year's san
diego comic-con was bursting with
superhero film and TV reveals for true
believers and newcomers alike there's a
lot to cover so let's dive right in
excelsior first up a practical set of
the Hulk's gladiator armor and weapons
from the upcoming thor ragnarok
currently shooting in australia was
revealed on the show floor ryan penagos
vice president and executive editor of
marvel digital media shared a video and
photos of the reveal on his twitter
account the armor looks very similar to
the set worn by the hulk in the popular
comic book storyline planet hulk there
was also a mockumentary short made by
Ragnar off director taika waititi
showing Thor living in an apartment on
Australia's Gold Coast with a bloke
named Daryl unfortunately the short
hasn't made its way online yet but as
soon as it does we'll be sure to let you
know after surprising fans who were
camped overnight in the long haul HQ
with selfies and general radness
Benedict Cumberbatch appeared on the
stage to introduce the latest Doctor
Strange trailer the trailer shows the
first time the renowned neurosurgeon
meets his mentor in the mystic arts the
ancient one before showing off the mind
bending reality shaping kaleidoscope
effects plus he puts his cape on like a
boss dr. Strange's the next film in
Marvel's jam-packed release schedule
coming out on November for this year
black panther director Ryan Coogler
revealed the full cast with chadwick
boseman reprising his role as two chela
/ black panther academy award-winning
actress lupita nyong'o as nakia Michael
B Jordan who Coogler last work with on
Creed as Eric kill manga and Dana
Guerrera as a koi a black panther is set
to release sometime in 2018 as part of
the Marvel Cinematic universes phase
three after months of speculation Marvel
hub confirmed that academy award winner
brie Larson will be Captain Marvel
Larson appeared on the Hall H stage to
confirm the news much to the delight of
fans and shared a picture of herself on
twitter with the caption call me Captain
Marvel Captain Marvel will be the
studio's first female lead superhero
film and is set for release in 2019
stuntman Mike himself Kurt Russell was
on hand with director James Gunn to
reveal who he will be playing in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 it was
revealed that he will be playing ego the
Living Planet who is obviously a living
planet the character can also assume
control of humanoid vessels which is how
he will appear in guardians vol 2 it was
also revealed that the group of misfits
will be coming to disneyland california
adventure in a new ride experience title
commission breakout disney imagineer Joe
rody revealed that the
will transport guests the lair of the
collector where they will join rocket in
an attempt to break his fellow Guardians
out of captivity the ride will take the
place of the existing twilight zone
tower of terror and will feature
multiple ride profiles and multiple
scores that will see the chaos unfold
the tune of great rock and roll a bunch
of muse has also dropped about marbles
very fruitful partnership with Netflix
the show that kicked it all off
daredevil has been confirmed for a third
season Marvel posted the confirmation on
Twitter after months of speculation that
their schedule may be too busy for
another outing for The Man Without Fear
alongside confirmation of more daredevil
marble showed off a trailer for the
upcoming Luke Cage series the
action-packed trailer shows the man with
the unbreakable skin taking on a group
of thugs in the show setting of Harlem
we also get a look at meh ishala Ali's
antagonist Cornell cottonmouth stopes
Luke Cage will premiere on netflix on
sep tember 30 rounding out the last
character necessary for the defenders a
teaser for iron fist has also dropped it
shows finn jones AKA Loras Tyrell and
Game of Thrones as Danny R and walking
barefoot through New York City before
punching a hole through a concrete wall
I poster was also revealed with a date
of 2017 the final Netflix teaser
revealed was a short clip for the team
up of daredevil Jessica Jones Luke Cage
and Iron Fist titled the defender's set
to a remix of nirvana's come as you are
and revealing absolutely nothing
substantial about the series it was the
most successful in sending me into a
full-on fanboy meltdown the defenders
will debut worldwide in 2017 marvel's
agents of shield is still going strong
and they've revealed the ghost writer
will be joining the show for season 4
this sep tember the show's version of
the character will be robbie reyes not
the original ghost writer but rather a
teen living in East LA who drives a
flaming car instead of a motorcycle and
he will be played by Gabriel Luna the
cast who have just started shooting
revealed the characters car on the show
floor finely marbled has shown a trailer
for their new joint series with effects
legion the drama follows superhero
legion AKA david holla a troubled man
who is diagnosed with schizophrenia as
he struggled with voices and visions
that may not be figments of his
imagination but glimpses of real events
while the comic character has strong
ties to the x-men this series has been
confirmed not to tie in with the x-men
movies with the Creator saying it is
more of a fable legion was created by
Noah Hawley who also created and wrote
the critically acclaimed Fargo TV series
and the show will start Dan Stevens as
Legion it will launch sometime in early
too
thousand and seventeen head to the site
where you can see full versions of all
the trailers mentioned info on all the
DC film and TV reveals as well as videos
of the best cosplay officiers comic-con
and for everything regarding super
soldiers mutants and lucky spider bite
victims keep swinging by games five